many people ask me questions about stoic
philosophy and practice I've created
this series to provide short answers to
the most common recurring or confusing
questions about stoicism this is an
excellent and commonly arise in question
is the philosophy of stoicism
self-centered and what they mean by that
really is is stoic ethics self-centered
the simple answer to this question is
that yes stoic philosophy is indeed
self-centered but and that's a very
important but it's not self-centered in
the way that most people use that term
to the exclusion of taking into account
or caring about or doing one's duties
towards other people it's understandable
that that answer may seem confusing or
even paradoxical to many people in our
culture because they have this
assumption and it is just an assumption
it's not you know something that you
automatically have to believe in that
either you are focusing on the self and
you're taking care of the self or you
are focusing on others this is the
age-old clash between egoism and
altruism and when it comes to ancient
moral theories the Stoics are very
similar to to some of the other key
moral theories in saying that this is a
false dichotomy at least in many cases
when it's elevated as an either/or
that's a sign of a lack of human moral
development
so the Stoics will say that yes for many
people either you can focus on the self
or focus on the other and because you
focus on the self you're going to find
yourself in conflicts with others but as
a human being
develops as a human being becomes
conscious of what it is not only to be
be rational but more specifically to be
to be just to be distinctively humane
you're going to inevitably widen your
scope
of concern to take in others this is a
doctrine that the Stoics called a OSIS
meaning bringing everybody into one
common community or one household one
boy goes if you like and it's viewed as
a natural development of the human being
who develops without the sorts of
impediments that that draw them into the
wrong path so you begin as a baby very
self-centered you're interested in your
own needs and your requirements and you
cry and you expect other people to take
care of you and that's okay but as you
expand as you take in more as you just
develop your distinctively rational
human nature then you start to take into
account other people and actually feel
affection towards them and recognize
duties towards them and the Stoics think
that it begins within the household but
it can be expanded outward in
ever-growing circles is the way that
here achlys the stoic but also Cicero
who is not a stoic but is writing about
stoic ethics in on duties this is the
way that they picture it these circles
expanding them outward to take in more
and more people until you finally take
in the entirety of humanity and people
that you don't know on some foreign
continent if you run into them Cicero
says well don't deny them water you know
if you can feed them feed them so you
know you begin with self-centeredness
and then you move as you develop as a
human being or as a stoic towards taking
into account other people so why would
people have the idea
specifically with stoicism that it is
self-centered I think there's two main
reasons I mean the Stoics themselves say
that we ought to be concerned with
ourselves and that every being you know
does want to preserve its own life bring
itself to flourishing and so it's quite
natural that we would think that there
is a focus on the self if you go a
little bit further
to stoic philosophy you'll even see the
Stoics talking about a continual
perception of one's own body of one's
own self by each individual being so so
that makes perfect sense the other thing
I think particularly contributes to it
is a misunderstanding of the famous
dichotomy of control
found in epictetus where Epictetus says
listen some things are up to you they're
within your purview they are you know
literally upon you at whom own they are
in your control in your powers how we
translate it other things are not and
those things that are in your control
your own thoughts your opinions your
desires and aversions your choices those
sorts of things are up to you all the
other things you know wealth bodily
health you know social status what other
people think how other people respond to
you that's not up to you that doesn't
mean that the stoic thinks that you
simply disengage yourself from
everything else including other people
as a matter of fact if you read
epictetus you'll see him very you know
clearly saying you actually have duties
towards those other people and that is
up to you so that falls on this side of
the night the academy of control
and how we use external things that's
also up to us and those external things
could be our relationships with other
people so you know a proper
understanding of the dichotomy of
control doesn't isolate the person out
and say screw everybody else they can
all sort their own business out I'm
gonna focus just on myself as a matter
of fact if you're going to develop as a
stoic you should find yourself being
more and more involved with other people
not in a pathological way where their
own problems their own mistaken views on
things their suffering ends up you know
infecting your own and drawing you into
you know their their circus if you like
if we want to use that not my monkeys
not my circus metaphor but in such a way
that you
can in fact properly respond to them
when you find them suffering so
Epictetus will say you know commiserate
with the person who has had a loss just
don't groan inwardly that is being
other-centered but in a way that's also
compatible with being self-centered so
the Stoics are indeed self-centered and
advocating a certain kind of
self-centeredness but it's one that's
very different than what we typically
mean by that term whether we're
deploring self-centeredness and others
or we're justifying a kind of
exaggerated self-centeredness so that we
can have what it is that we want and not
care about others
the Stoics would say that that
understanding of self-centeredness is
actually a deficient understanding of it
and reflective of a poorly developed
character on the part of both people
what the Stoics are advocating is a
truly rational self-centeredness one
that that takes into account others
because our rational nature when it
develops has us engaging with and caring
about and taking care of other people if
you found this answer helpful for you
then please share it with others who
might benefit from it this work is
entirely supported by crowdfunding on my
patreon site so if you find it valuable
consider becoming a supporter at
patreon.com slash Saddler